[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'ancient
parler sport l'émission à ne pas manquer
si vous êtes un amoureux du sport local
pour m'accompagner aujourd'hui cinq
chroniqueurs sont autour de cette table
sont au pic de leur forme pour vous
donner le meilleur d'eux-mêmes
présentation en musique
elle commence à ma droite les émissions
il les prépare pendant plus de deux
semaines non stop pour être au top le
jour j il ne donne qu'une heures par
nuit
c'est un acharné de travail le capitaine
yann dujarrier du club de vélizy 78
piste à août 2010 78 est avec nous pour
michael alors vous avez trouvé
l'émission
alors moi une heure et une heure par
sieste c'est moi c'est une heure
d'assister à ces vignobles une heure par
jour après la nuit c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus long donc vous travaillez
pas l'émission je chie si le chien
je suis très très efficace quand je
travaille on passe de l'autre côté à
musique ses fans l'ont un pleuré lors de
sa dernière émission mais elle est de
retour aujourd'hui après un tome que
d'absence à nous vient tout droit de
versailles
elle vous a manqué à nous a manqué notre
ambassadrice de charme
hélène de la grange spécialiste du pole
dance à versailles je suis ravi de
revenir à une faire pleurer là avec ton
de tentes compliments comme ça m'a reçu
des lettres de fans en tout cas nous
demander pourquoi vous n'étiez pas là
mais bon voilà je n'ai pas pu mais moi
je suis de retour
on passe de l'autre côté un musée qui
nous vient lui aussi de versailles
toujours parfaitement habillé à la james
bond l'homme au pistolet d'or n'a pas de
permis de tuer aujourd'hui il sort le
service de sa majesté le sport et non
pas dans un casino royale pierre
chevallier de rugby club de versailles
nous fait l'honneur de venir sur ce talk
bonjour pierre salut michael forme et
bonheur à tous quand allez-vous très
bien près de présentation comme celle là
en plus avec ça ça rime avec le hashtag
du du rugby-club versailles qui était
qui pistait la voie royale
vers la fédérale 3 comme on a atteint
l'objectif c'est bien ça reste bien
c'est parfait en passe de l'autre côté
mesdames et messieurs je demande le
silence sur ce plateau musique vous
reconnaissez forcément sa musique son
come back était plus attendue que celui
de michael jordan en ligue 1 ou 2
zinedine zidane en équipe de france le
légendaire le mythique l'incroyable vous
ne rêvez pas mustapha larfaoui tu avec
nous sur ce plateau président c'est vrai
que c'est l'honneur c'est fabuleux comme
présent se joue au mental et vous c'est
ça va mal mais au moment de l'émission
pour moi parce que pour les autres c'est
vous bien évidemment merci très bien je
vais rester dans cet âge ici merci pour
l'invitation ont été remis de l'autre
côté musique une autre personne
d'exception et sur ce plateau et les
cavaliers international il nous vient de
plaisir on le surnomme le zorro
yvelinois le vengeur masqué qui est venu
sans mascara ou contre l autriche est
avec nous comment allez vous raul tué
père michael et vous très bien moi je
vais très bien avec cinq chroniqueurs au
top de leur foi bonjour aujourd'hui 6
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission va parler de foot us les
templiers d'elancourt on perdre l'un de
leurs joueurs
mathis ducrocq que l'on va voir à
l'écran avec ses longs cheveux joueurs
des moins de 19 ans du club va intégrer
l'équipe canadienne des électriks
football une équipe qui évolue à un
niveau juste avant l'université
pour le moment il restera quelques
semaines au club avant de s'envoler vers
de nouveaux objectifs de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
est-ce que ça valorise le travail des
templiers un départ comme celui là il ya
dix jarrier oui oui on sait très bien
que le foot américain il ya quand même
une autre une autre dimension sur le
continent américain
donc c'est vrai que d'un joueur formé au
club qui peut aller aller jouer et qui
est demandée pour arriver sur continent
américain
même si c'est pas encore sur les ligues
majeures c'est c'est une vraie
satisfaction pour le pour le club
hellène
mais je rejoins ce chrétienne non non
vraiment toute façon c'est une
valorisation un tapis de l'encours oui
oui et puis si les réclames et ou qui
possèdent une possibilité d'aller encore
perdu
comment dire travailler ces techniques
progresser et c'est merci jan il faut y
aller c'est une étape importante dans sa
carrière et puis même pour le club de
savoir qu il forme des joueurs qui vont
progresser ailleurs et j lui-même que
n'importe quel sportif qui démarre pour
faire ce type de sport
il se dit au tout début si un jour je
peux partir aux us je le fais quoi voilà
c'est dans ce rêve bien sûr que le
pourcentage est un film de ceux qui vont
qu'ils vont réussir mais je pense que ce
n'est pas encore une équipe
professionnelle
c'est une équipe avec un poste
universitaire pour montrer vous avez
barbarie est là
la valorisation allait évidemment pour
le club c'est le club formateur celui
qui lui donne entre guillemets qui fait
passer à la fois les codes de ce sport
qui met en place tous les outils pour le
faire grandir
mais la valorisation c'est le joueur qui
la donne à son club
c'est lui qu'on est valorisée pour
partir mais quel que soit son bord quand
on est moins au club de foot de trappes
c'est aller c'est un déchirement de voir
partir des gens humainement mais c'est
un bonheur de les voir partir ce samedi
surtout si c'est pour jouer sur un
niveau supérieur donc là on parle des
états unis pour le foot mais des
américains qui veulent venir en france
pour le 5ème pour le football
le nôtre donc le fait d'aller là où le
niveau est bon c'est valorisant pour le
club formateur mais c'est bon pour le
joueur et c'est le joueur qui apporte
cette plus value quelque part au club
particulièrement dense où tu es si
football américain précisément il ya
américain c'est un sport qui est pas on
va dire qui est atypique otepää qui est
pas historique en europe et notamment en
france donc qu'un jeune comme celui là
puisse aller s'aguerrir aux états unis
prendre de la technique prend de
l'enseignement au prendre de
l'expérience l'a rapporté en france
à mon avis c'est sale et c'est ça
l'objectif c'est tout bon pour le joueur
comme disait mustapha pour le club
également
et il faut juste espérer pour les
templiers que c'est pas le meilleur
élément le meilleur joueur à son poste
pour pas qu'ils soient trop d habiller
pendant pendant son séjour aux us mais
de toute façon s'il le récupère et quand
ils le récupéreront ça sera une valeur
ajoutée raul les deux sont gagnant
finalement dans l'histoire pour résumer
je le club salue la paix au club
un premier bon référencement et pour
ceux pour ce genre de toute façon et
c'est un palier qui est indispensable
pour lui et quand le sport ne fait pas
partie de la de la culture du pays il
est indispensable pour quelqu'un de
talent de vite prendre son envol pour
aller jouer dans la cour des grands donc
je pense que le point positif est dans
les deux camps est majoritaire on peut
en parler sur ce sujet quand même le
souhaite bon courage
faciles de sa carrière nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler d'équitation un jeune athlète
handicapée s'est lancé le défi de
participer aux jeux paralympiques de
2024 nous ferons également un coup de
projecteur sur le lien entre sport et
politique mais avant de développer ces
thèmes
on va parler à football dans ce talk
[Musique]
on commence ce tour d'horizon de
l'actualité sportive part du football la
fédération française de football
envisage de vendre offre un centre
d'entraînement semblable à
clairefontaine à la chine
le site construit dans le sud des
yvelines est mondialement connu pour
avoir été les équipes de france de
football avec toutes les technologies de
dernière génération pour les sportifs le
président de la fff noël le graet
voudrait vendre le savoir faire de ce
site pour une implantation aux alentours
de pékin si le deal se fait ce serait
une grande première mondiale la question
sur ce thème est ce que vous êtes pour
ou contre vous votez versé pour le
segment des très bien dur où je pourrais
être en contradiction mais un loyer du
rouge ces messieurs du rouge prévost et
là je suis un peu je fais un petit dieu
est avec vous et moi
pierre chevallier alors elle m je suis
un peu partagé parce que vendre toujours
à l'étranger dévoile à des structures
des capacités et des toutous ses
complexes là ça me moi ça me chagrine un
peu
alors oui une histoire d'investisseurs
il ya tout ça mais ça me
ça me chagrine un peu donc toutes les
mains non j'aime bien que ça reste
voilà dans le pays et que ce soit pas
toujours toujours racheter par
l'extérieur ou sur vous si je peux juste
après juste après y'a déjà je trouve que
c'est un an parlait justement d'échangés
d'expériences pour le symbole américain
lassés du chou c'est du football et
surtout on parle pas forcément dans ce
cas précis de sport ni de méthode dit de
techniques ni vraiment de ce qui fait
par exemple la spécificité ou le sel ou
la performance de l'équipe de france
deux fois championne du monde
on parle d'un écrin technique d'un écrin
dans l'écrin de ses neuf précédentes et
l'infrastructure elle même on parle d'un
mode d'un bâtiment surnom sûrement de
l'équipement qui est de dos des
technologies de pointe qui sont qui sont
à l'intérieur mais on ne vend pas notre
âme et on ne vend pas notre savoir faire
sur l'équipe de france par ce biais là
donc c'est à la limite le savoir faire
technique de la france qui s'exporte
reste à savoir si c'est par exemple pour
l'équipe nationale de chine ou pour des
clubs professionnels
ça serait parfait pour l'équipe
nationale de chine donc on est on est
dans un secteur dans un secteur connu
qui a fait ses preuves encore une fois
deux fois sur le toit mondiale pour
l'équipe de france
je ne pense pas qu'on ait à perdre je
parle même pas du financier mais je ne
pense pas qu'on ait à perdre à vendre ce
savoir-faire qui a fait ses preuves
encore une fois on parle on parle de
technique on parle de matériel on parle
d'infrastructures
on ne parle pas du savoir faire
technique sportive de l'équipe de france
de foot donc je pense que c'est une
bonne chose que ce savoir-faire français
s'exporte et notamment notamment sur un
marché qui comme comme sur le marché
économique chinois est en plein boom
parce que pierre chevallier vous a
convaincu
vous êtes toujours de la vie fait
d'agents je suis toujours je suis
toujours rouge et et pour qu'une salle
donc voilà c'est la raison pour laquelle
je suis rouge c'est parce que le pays
acheteur c'est la chine rouge la matière
et parce que la chine c'est le pays de
la copie voilà donc du coup qu'est ce
qui nous prouve qu'ils ne vont pas
copier ce domaine et pour pouvoir y
apporter ses des améliorations pour
ensuite de faire à nouveau le fer
exporté après c'est ce qui fait un peu
déjà passé pour nous tempère dans vos
propos dans le sens que la chine n'est à
l'heure actuelle pas une grande nation
du football
voilà les soixante quatorzième ce
verdissement fifa pour maison participer
seulement une fois la coupe du monde
c'était en 2002 l'équipe avait perdu ses
trois matches dont 1 4 à 0 contre le
brésil on est loin de vendre le
savoir-faire à l'argentine par exemple
on met championnat car elle suit
maintenant la chine a prouvé dans
beaucoup d'autres sports qu'ils étaient
capables de devenir les numéros un
mondiaux et je pense que je pense que la
chine à la densité humaine pour pouvoir
le devenir
alors on sera peut-être plus sur cette
terre pour au moment où ce sera aux mots
se sera produit sur tout le staff a
parce qu'il a un peu d'avancé sur nous
mais mais voilà n'a pas reculé mais
c'est vrai que non je vais juste un
petit peu de mal par rapport au fait que
la chine soit le pays de la copie est
donc et surtout ils ont cette capacité
d'adaptation sur beaucoup d'autres
sports
à pouvoir faire travailler leurs
athlètes pour devenir les meilleurs donc
pour moi je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
besoin de ça et c'est peut-être faire
ceci est la branche charité long nez
on est assis parce que c'était justement
leur donner un coup d'un coup de pouce
qui la fera gagner beaucoup d'années et
et c'est peut-être dommage
mustapha le meilleur argument était
donnée donc je vais simplement relevé ce
qui est de notre ami yann alors c'est le
privilège de l'âge c'est aussi avoir un
peu de recul et un peu de sagesse
et tempéré pour le coup ce que tu dis
d'abord la peur n'évite pas le danger
donc si on a peur il ya un danger on
l'évitera pas forcément de cette manière
premièrement deuxièmement si c'est pas
la france qui le fait probablement ce
sera d'autres nations qu'ils le
faisaient et on peut penser à des
nations qui tienne la route quand même
dans le foot un ancien brésil par
exemple ça a joué on pense à l'allemagne
qui savent pendant deux dispositions
différentes donc la peur n'évite pas le
danger il peut très bien que d'autres le
fassent
troisièmement moi je reviens à gré soit
la france pour une raison très simple
c'est que moi je considère que
l'excellence à la française que ce soit
dans le luxe ils cherchent à nos
copieuse et 1
et pourtant ô demeure le numéro un du
luxe on aura toujours une longueur
d'avancé
combien même on partagerait des choses
ou copier il ya la culture c'est quelque
chose qu'on appréhende pas simplement en
copiant une culture c'est beaucoup plus
profond
on l'a dans le luxe on l'a dans deux
domaines d'excellence laissant les
copier dans l'aéronautique par exemple
là on a toujours une longueur d'avancé
parce que la france c'est pas simplement
aujourd'hui qu'elle a appris des choses
et qu'elle ait transmis aujourd'hui
c'est que sais je veux dire c'est des
milliers d'années d'expérience et ça ça
compte pour une nation et enfin pour
terminer
combien même il nous copierait on a
besoin d'autres nations de très haut
niveau ça veut dire qu'il viendra notre
niveau que ça permettra la fronde est
encore plus excellence pour se rivaliser
que des nations excellente et enfin pour
terminer en 5e arr
parce que là tu m'a cherchée et tu
cherches le vieux
je mettrai 5e arguments le 5e dont je ne
me souviens pas je plains et c'est vrai
que ça reste aussi un domaine économique
il faut pas avoir peur de valoriser ces
peuples non demain un demi point 2 de
pib cercle vendre le sport
l'excellence dans le sport c'est des
infrastructures c'est des ingénieurs
c'est des sportifs qui vont aller
chercher faire du préfet il ya un
domaine économique qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer non plus donc faut pas en
avoir peur de ça d'accord départ du mans
le 6e billet vert allez les verts c'est
justement le fait que que ce soit la
conclusion de 20 ans le football au plus
haut niveau 20 de 98 premier titre à
2018 deuxième titre pour l'équipe de
france il non préparés ils l'ont
façonnée à clairefontaine si ça permet
justement à d'autres nations de se
hisser l'équipe de france pour que ce
soit une compétition franche et virile
mais correcte car on sait très bien
qu'au bout du monde commun c'est qu'on a
vu des des émergents m'attendais pas la
fin de tableau était inattendue avant
d'avoir un championnat du monde comme le
comme le la ligue 1 ou talent psg tout
seul et des équipes se connaît où on dit
finalement le psg n'est pas bon parce
que j'ai c'est la suisse et la france y
est il faudrait aussi c'est la france
qui permet de ce niveau alors on est
bien parce que l'islande n'a pas
démérité des petites équipes entre
guillemets n'ont pas démérité donc ça se
transforme beaucoup plus vite qu'on ne
le pense moi j'ai vu le japon joué
franchement très belle équipe
on pourrait continuer leur japon sur ce
sujet en tout cas noël le graet envisage
de faire ce projet mais ce n'est pas
encore signé je le précise ce n'est pas
encore officiel
on continue à part du football la coupe
du monde féminine commence le 7 juin et
les y vivent ont participé à cette
grande fête la fifa et le comité
d'organisation retenu croissy-sur-seine
comme terrain d'entraînement pour quatre
équipes nationales l'équipe de france
l'afrique du sud l'écossé la dream team
américaine vont s'entraîner sur le site
à partir du 3 juin
les équipements avaient déjà été
utilisés
l'équipe de russie pendant l'euro 2016
on écoute le maire de la commune au
micro de tv 78 c'est une surprise non
c'est la continuation de ce qu'on avait
déjà engagé avec l'euro 2016 et puis
l'équipe d'angleterre à l'aide à prix
qui est venu s'entraîner ici
donc effectivement on avait candidaté
pour la coupe du monde l'équipe de
france et premier numéro un mondial
l'équipe des états unis où il abreuve de
convenir bien sûr discale intéressant
c'est qu'il aura des entraînements
ouverts
donc on pourra faire profiter nos jeunes
sportifs ils pourront côtoyer des
sportifs de haut niveau et ça c'est
aussi très important pour moi
la 8e édition de la coupe du monde
féminine se déroulera du 7 juin au 7
juillet dans l'hexagone
est-ce que croissy sur seine a raison de
continuer à recevoir des équipes
nationales
ce n'est pas encore la question sur ce
thème j'oppose rabaisser un petit peu
plus tard mustapha non c'est quoi cette
disposition prise par le maire c'est
choquant non je plaisante évidemment cui
mais je voudrais tout de suite est ce
que ça apporte à une fille finalement de
recevoir une équipe nationale comme cela
l'équipe nationale alors d'abord ça ça
ça engage la commune sur des
responsabilités qui sont énormes qu'on
reçoit une équipe nationale il ya le
choix qui est fait par cette équipe
internationale et la ville qui reçoit
dans son engagement
par définition elle prend des
responsabilités elle doit en être à la
hauteur
donc en général c'est bénéfique pour la
ville parce que on s'occupe des
installations pour les mettre vraiment
au meilleur niveau
donc là déjà c'est un engagement positif
pour la vie ensuite ça crée de
l'effervescence pour ce sport dans sa
ville donc c'est à la fois techniquement
favorable et pour l'ambiance autour du
sport et pour la ville
ça reste un élément important et puis
troisièmement bas la preuve on parle
croissy-sur-seine c'est pas des gens qui
on parle tous les jours on appellera
aussi moi qui est à la fois
cette visibilité on va s'occuper des
installations qui profiteront aux
joueurs après la coupe du monde c'était
vrai pour la coupe du monde masculine
et donc voilà donc c'est bon pour
croatie c'est bon pour les installations
c'est bon pour le sport raul vous êtes
d'accord avec moi
oui tout à fait
me wehrli c'est parfait soit il est né
et où il faut qu'on en parle c'est pas
bien ce qui se passe on en parle sauf
peut être indispensable dans tous les
cas que pour pour des villes que dès que
des événements suscitent le challenge et
mettre à l'épreuve leur capacité à se
mettre à la hauteur d'un événement d'une
d'un regroupement et que et que une
énergie supplémentaire secret au sein de
ces de cette ville et c'est logique
finalement qu'une ville comme cela sous
lens dans ce type d'opération à ce
qu'ils ont eue de la russie en 2016 on
disait précédemment comme camp de base
ils ont également eu l'angleterre pour
un match amical un petit peu plus tard
finalement ça sort dans l'adn du club
phare de la ville des roses et où le
recul pour pour les reins nécessaire
pour encaisser cet événement rare
surtout que d'autres villes de phase 1
trappe devrait se lancer justement la
question sur ce thème si ce genre de 2,2
voilà on a besoin de ça vous y êtes
apple justement la question sur ce thème
un seul site dans les yvelines
est ce que c'est une déception oui ou
non vous votez non ce n'est pas une
déception
attrape déception pourtant un petit duel
entre moustapha et pierre bienvault
commencer je pense comme ça soit une
déception dans la mesure où les
candidatures sont ouvertes c'est des
dossiers des dossiers c'est assez large
des gros qu'elle était charge sur mon
prêt pour accueillir ces équipes
nationales qui je précise je pense
parlent entre elles les équipes
internationales vous rappeliez un gros
ce que croatie avait accueilli jusqu'à
maintenant les équipes internationales
se passe les tuyaux une ville qui les
reçoit bien dans lequel ils peuvent bien
préparé la compétition et dans lequel et
éventuellement y performent
c'est un tuyau qu'on se passe donc là je
pense que la réputation de croatie est
bonne hélas là l'occasion unique de
frapper un grand coup
orio en recevant quatre équipes et c'est
ce qui me fait dire non ce n'est pas une
déception c'est que pour tous les
yvelinois il ya un il ya un endroit qui
centralise toutes les attentions
peut-être mais au moins qui permet de
voir du football pendant toute la coupe
du monde toute la coupe du monde d'avoir
toujours une équipe à suivre et à
regarder en plus c'est pas d'essai pas
les plus petites équipes qui sont reçus
avec les amériques et de l'équipe de
france ont évidemment en tête
donc je pense que c'est c'est une chance
qu'a su saisir quand six sur scène c'est
une chance pour les yvelinois d'avoir un
linceul lieu unité de lieu justement
pour aller voir du football féminin
et dans cette exposition est cette
évolution du football féminin
c'est une très bonne chose de pouvoir
justement lui donner cette exposition la
mustapha ma déception elle n'est pas sur
le fait que ça soit croatie sur scène en
2003 va bien je suis très heureux pour
eux et c'est bien ce soit une ville
d'ailleurs le département qui en
bénéficient moi ma déception avec ce que
d'autres communes n'ai pas réussi aussi
à se glisser la haute-vienne le dire
certains effectivement rappelle que pour
l'heure voire 2016
il y avait clairefontaine qui a
accueilli l'équipe de france et
versailles accueillait l'équipe
d'irlande opération que croise assure
celui qui accueillait la rue son bord
ont donc la joie je valais de l'argument
donc ma déception elle n'est pas sûre
croatie qui a su se mettre en valeur et
qui a gagné ça reste les yvelines on
consent on s'en réjouit c'est juste ma
déception elle et que d'autres parce que
la question c'est est pourquoi pas ça
sur site pour moi ma question c'est un
seul organisme est ce que c'est une des
scènes science moi et ma déception c'est
le fait que ça tu sais être croatie et
trappes par exemple parce qu'à un moment
donné ça nécessite de travailler les
installations ça nécessite que la
réputation soi même quand on a parlé ça
nécessite qui parle de trappes au
différemment donc oui c'est bon et
pourquoi pas ce que tu rappes je connais
un peu et parce que tragi un engagement
très particulier depuis maintenant 16
ans alors travail en gamme et des
rumeurs ont fait inscrire sur la ville
de trappes qui pouvait organiser
justement des entraînements on peut
maintenant la coupe du monde
c'était en tout cas le dossier a été
évoqué je ne sais pas si ça a pu arriver
il n'est pas arrivé jusqu'à mon
bureau de président de club à l'époque
président d'honneur aujourd'hui pour
donner des conseils mais bien sûr que
c'est important que les dossiers
arrivent également à trappes et pardonne
mode par les trams c'est juste que j'y
suis implanté depuis 16 ans et que j'ai
un peu le jeu connaît un peu le sujet
mais je répète croatie bravo que
d'autres puissent se hisser au même
niveau on est plusieurs sites et que ça
valorise le département travaille de
plus en ville hélène versailles aurait
dû candidate et versailles pour une vie
qui a reçu l'équipe d'irlande le diseur
de la censure qui peuvent accueillir des
grosses équipes si versailles peu à
versailles doit donc non mais c'est vrai
mais je pense que c'est ça d'être
attrapé vraiment voilà c'était la
question versailles france que versa et
déjà accueilli donc je pense que ma
réponse est oui train peut mener du
boulot là la chose qui me gêne pas je
pense que c'est senna le tallec il faut
noter qu'ils puissent un peu inversés
comportant des six et non c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'il ya du boulot mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que dans l'esprit
mais c'est dans l'esprit certainement il
faut candidate et vous présenter parce
que sa chasse à cette série sont
indignes de timing et d'intérêts
d'intérêt est ce que versailles
versailles a dû avoir l'occasion de se
positionner à une trappe également
sûrement est-ce que c'est pas une
question de choix dans la mandature
municipale sur de se dire on parle par
pas en proposant sachant que versait
accueillera les jo de 2024 et la ligne
commencent à se positionner sur les jo
de 2024 déjà donne puisque sur la côte
est ouvrier c'est ça qu'il était déjà en
train de focaliser sur cette échéance là
monde de rugby 2015 il ya le monde la
ryder cup il était dessus avec une
équipe d'angleterre en équitation en
2007 de bille c'est peut-être peut-être
pas le bon timing pour la ville de
versailles où les autres municipalités
de l'est il faut se fixer des objectifs
on est bien d'accord sur le timing est
bien d'accord sont fait que ça soit des
dossiers moins solides pour des tas de
raisons techniques il faut se fixer des
objectifs sinon ça n'avance pas et
trappe si c'est l'image qu'on en a
aujourd'hui il y en aura peut-être une
autre demain en tout cas félicitations à
croix c'est sur celle qui va accueillir
vingt quatre équipes nationales du 7
juin au 7 juillet du coup sur leur
terrain d'entraînement
on va maintenant fermer cette page
football pour parler équitation dans
notre focus du jour de l'équitation dans
ceux ci en parler sport aujourd'hui
focus sur un jeune ville provient adrien
coller cet athlète handisport de 24 ans
handicapée du côté gauche est devenu en
l'espace d'un an l'un des meilleurs
cavaliers de la région alors qu'il
n'était jamais monté sur un cheval avant
tout cela grâce à sa force de caractère
mais également grâce à son lien avec son
cheval zénith on écoute adrien collet
c'est une relation très fusionnelle dès
que c'est un châle dkim voix il bat il
sort la tête de son box où dès qu'il
entend la voiture arrivait pas
ristournes
il sait que c'est moi qui arrive donc
après l'expliqué réellement je sais pas
c'est vraiment un sentiment raul vous
qui êtes notre spécialiste
équitation comment il explique ce
rapport à l'animal
d'abord je suis très ému et merci
michael de remettre le projecteur sur
parce que tout chercher dans mon centre
et qu'est-ce que ça se passe rappelez
moi la question comment l'expliquer ce
rapport aux autres
adrien est l'animal le rapport à
l'animal dans son île et son insecte
façon sauvage et c'est quelque chose de
très particulier
les recherches sur sur le l'équithérapie
au niveau du handicap entre vont
commencer à peu près dans la fin des
années 80 90 parlons et on s'est rendu
compte très rapidement que les chevaux
dans certaines situations et face à
certaines personnes en particulier les
individus handicapés ou différent des
autres
adopter un comportement spécifique et
par très souvent comme par exemple sur
des chevaux très très turbulent d'un
seul coup développer un instinct très
protecteur pour c'est pour ces cavaliers
là donc il est sûr d'ailleurs on l'a vu
manger on a vu à maintes reprise
énormément de résultats sur le sur le
handicap
mais de là en projeter un sur la scène
sur la compétition ça c'est encore autre
chose
ça vous surprend autour de cette table
hélène non je pense que c'est vraiment
le binôme qui fait le fait de résultats
pour le coup les capacités de cavaliers
évidemment après le cheval aussi mais
c'est l'ensemble des deux qui qui permet
d'arriver à ce résultat là en fait c'est
ce que tu disais le l'entendent qui a le
fait que le cheval s'adapte aussi aux
cavaliers avec le cavalier du coup peut
grandir à la au niveau des techniques au
niveau de la discipline c'est et puis
l'attachement qui laboure son choix elle
parce qu'on le voit une en parle et je
pense que le cheval part et c'est
vraiment l'ensemble des deux qui qui
permet d'aller dans une compétition
comme ça et une avancée surprend par
alger une femme cavalière depuis une
trentaine d'années qui pratique
l'équitation et l'équithérapie depuis
depuis très nombreuses années et ce qui
est je suis comme raul très ému par ce
genre de menaces que je trouve
absolument fantastique et humainement
très forte c'est que c'est le lien quasi
explicable qu'il peut y avoir entre un
animal en l'occurrence un cheval et un
enfant ou un adulte handicapé j'ai vu
j'ai assisté à des scènes aussi avec
avec des enfants autistes qui s'ouvre
qui s'ouvre au monde extérieur grâce à
ce qu'on va dire sixième sens des
chevaux et qui comme disait comme le
rappelait raul ont une attitude qui
s'adapte et c'est ça c'est ça le plus
dingue qui s'adapte complètement à
l'interlocuteur et à l'enfant qu'ils ont
en face d'eux je ne sais pas si vous
avez vu aussi récemment une vidéo d'un
cheval qui est qui faisait de la voltige
avec qui on faisait la voltige et son
maître depuis quand il a vu que sont le
cheval avait un avait une capacité
justement à détecter certaines maladies
et surtout à faire du bien aux hommes
l'a amené dans des hôpitaux et on voit
ce cheval dans des couloirs d'hôpital et
d'aller de chambre en chambre et
s'arrêter uniquement par exemple devant
les chambres de deux patients atteints
de cancer et ils ont vu des résultats
aux dires des médecins traitants
inexplicable ça a trait à l'irrationnel
mais en tout cas ça fonctionne et c'est
ce jeune garçon qui a un qui mérite tout
le respect qui est qui et qui vit une
histoire fantastique avec son cheval est
là pour le là pour le montrer
donc ça va moi je découvre le reportage
comme vous c'est un coup à chialer quoi
de cesser ses chaussées précieux c'est
voilà c'est une belle histoire déjà rien
que ça moi ça me d'émotion
et ouais c'est un coach il est tellement
ça fait plaisir tout simplement juste
plaisir
pour le reste j'ai entendu beaucoup
d'histoires aussi de ce type là quand
même
comme ce cheval qu'on amène dans
l'hôpital et qui s'arrête lui qui
choisit finalement la ville là où il
pense servir le cheval s'arrête là où il
pense qui peut servir à quelque chose et
on n'explique pas donc je vais pas
chercher à l'expliquer mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que c'est toujours pareil les
les couples ski ski ce qui fait que ça
fonctionne bien
bah c'est vrai entre deux êtres sais pas
pourquoi ça fonctionne bien entre deux
êtres et que ce soit un cheval un homme
une femme
bref tout ce qui fait que j'entends un
cheval avec un homme ou un cheval avec
une femme et deux êtres en l'occurrence
bayer des choses qui s'explique pas la
raison du coeur c'est ça ou la raison
que la réservation n'a pas donc c'est
d'abord une belle histoire mes parents
j'ai des questions pour le coup si je
peux poser une question notre ami
malaisie série mustapha est ce que parce
que l'on parle quand même de haut niveau
là parle pas simplement du 1e mai c'est
un handicap
c'est là toute la particularité de rien
c'est vraiment pour le coup un handicap
il est handicapé c'est selon qu'est ce
que j'avais vu ce moment ça me vient au
contraire saleh des lieux celui à face à
lui a fait prendre beaucoup d'avancé
comme je l'expliquais à michael savoir
que c'est un garçon qui se bat tous les
matins depuis qu'ils se lèvent contre un
handicap donc mais finalement le fait
d'affronter les sacrifices et les la
discipline qu'impose le sport en
compétition bat produit c'est une
rigolade
enfin finalement c'est ce qui lui a fait
prendre beaucoup d'avancé
quelqu'un de particulièrement mais la
15e en l2 et de mac et spacieux clinique
était technique sert qu'il a un handicap
physique
je ne sais pas lequel on me dit parfois
tellement il est mauvais quand on quand
on saute en obstacle il ya des positions
acquises à cheval les parties les plus
les plus les articulations les plus
sollicités sont les chevilles
genou donc articulations dont il est
complètement handicapé donc donc été
bien handicapé sur la maison tous les
deux tout son nez mais il est sûr c'est
que ce mécanisme pourra lancer de régler
de fer en place avec la voie libre à
être autorisées sur les compétitions
internationales sincèrement je suis ravi
il n'a pas un handicap qui fait que dans
sa tête il se bat plus que les autres il
a vraiment un handicap sur le sport ça
veut dire il est sur les dix matches on
a vu là on voit que il a quand même une
vraie tenue de cavaliers quoi ils
travaillent
quelqu'un qui travaille comme ça et on
voit bien qu'on voit bien que sa jambe
gauche elle est atrophié par rapport à
celles issues d'un acharnement
j'ai participé aux championnats du monde
handisport l'année dernière au mois deux
mois de mars pour une première fois et
on voit des donc c'était sûr du vélo et
j'étais pilote d'un athlète
malvoyants mais voilà sur un tandem et
c'est vrai que sur cet événement là j'ai
vu des prix des leçons de vie pendant
une semaine avec des des gens qui ont
toujours le sourire
quoi qu'il advienne sauf que l'on n'est
pas dans le handisport puisqu'il
s'entraîne parmi les valides
non merci alors qui va concourir mais il
va vite il veut qu'on s'était déjà
plaint aujourd'hui sur le court
justement aujourd'hui abriel a qu'un
seul objectif en tête du coc avec son
entraîneur qui le suit depuis un an
viser les jeux olympiques les jeux
paralympiques 2024 à paris en tant
qu'athlète handisport on écoute je
m'entraîne pour ça de base
j'ai dès que je monte à cheval je me dis
allez adrien fait l'effort dans peu de
temps il ya sans doute les bio qui sont
à la porte
la question sur ce thème adrien collet
peut-il aller aux jo de 2024 ou jeux
paralympiques pour le débat juste la
question avec les autres c est ce qui
n'est pas s'il est déjà trop tard pour
une visée tokyo 2020 quoi parce que ça
laisse encore un an mais encore un an et
demi pour pouvoir travailler
est ce que le fait que les critères de
sélection sont des fonds déjà qu'il est
il est barré pour pour tokyo est donc en
effet les gens ce peut être par idw 24
mai
moi je vois là pour moi un an et demi
c'est énorme
sur le papier non le il faut savoir que
forcément les jeux olympiques sont des
jeux qui sont beaucoup moins côtoyé que
les jeux zona que les jeux olympiques je
dirais anormaux voilà pour valide donc
donc donc si vous voulez tout ce qui est
des délais administratifs sont beaucoup
moins long quand légion ont lieu en
juillet en août jusqu'à avril
on peut encore réglé rêver certains
papiers certaines sélections
le problème n'est pas là et d'un point
de vue technique je pense qu adrien un
an ça lui suffirait pour avoir le niveau
parce que c'est quelqu'un de
particulièrement 2 le problème c'est le
cheval l'équitation c'est un petit peu
comme comme tous ces sports automobiles
nous sommes quand même tributaire de la
machine ou de l'animal que nous pilotons
donc je suis manipulé
non pour l'instant c'est pour ça que
nous faisons en essayant de faire des
appels aux sponsors et de trouver des
partenaires pour financer d'abord
l'achat d'un cheval qui aurait le niveau
de l'emmener jusqu'au jusqu'au jo ainsi
que tout l'entretien et les les
déplacements que ça engendrerait parce
que au même titre que pour les valides
il faut il faut participer à des
compétitions qui ont lieu à l'autre bout
du monde donc
la relation particulière qu'il a avec ce
cheval ça peut pas faire la différence
parce qu il est il a déjà su remonter
jusqu'au bout
voilà un jeu qui sort de nulle part
qu'on a sauvés de la corrida il ya une
dizaine d'années au fin fond du portugal
pas du tout destiné à faire du saut
d'obstacles si je suis elle est arrivé à
ce niveau c'est grâce à adrian newey
alors c'est réciproque plus ou moins
mais c'est en tous les cas il a
transcendé son cheval l'a déjà je pense
que là après il faudra que notre cheval
prennent le relais et avec il faudrait
qu'elle fit j'aurais bien aimé qu'ils
ayant son je peux faire ça fait des
économies qu'ils dépenseront pas une
thune il mangera mieux c'est désobliger
vous coupez l'objet d'avancées dans
l'émission on ouvre maintenant ils page
pas peut-être long modern sport
olympique depuis 1912 qui regroupe cinq
disciplines les screen la natation
l'équitation le tir au pistolet et la
course à pied à versailles un
franco-tunisien vise les jo de 2024 son
nom wade chouachi il s'entraîne tous les
jours pour atteindre cet objectif nous
l'avons reçue lors de l'émission sept
huit sports oms l'écoutent
à l'origine je suis basketteurs je fais
principalement du basket et un peu de
judo et
avec l'âge on nous dit que on devient
plus fatigués qu'on a plus les
pathologies qu'il faut faire de la
natation donc j'ai commencé un petit peu
où ce sport là pour avoir une activité
d'activité physique
j'ai retrouvé l'esprit de compétition et
ainsi de suite et de fil en aiguille on
apprend qu'à tunisie n'a participé
qu'une seule fois aux jo en 1971 donne
un objectif et et ensuite on se donne
les moyens
la question sur ce thème peut-il aller
aux jo de 2024
il a 38 ans et je rappelle il travaille
entre 20 et 30 heures par semaine au
niveau des entraînements est-ce qu'il
peut aller aux jo de 2024
moi je veux pas me fâcher avec donc je
mets du roulèr pas pour l'instant solide
jugement je sais je sais pour être
honnête je ne sais pas pour moi il ya
une question de délai de 1024 c'est loin
et la 38 38 ans et dabo ce s'entraîner
beaucoup c'est quand même des
disciplines qu'il ya des disciplines
qu'ils n'ont des capacités physiques
je suis fou sur le et physiques et
techniques bien sûr mais qu'il faut
qu'il faut assumer à 40
il dort à quel âge donc voilà enfin
quand j'étais enfant demande et en
quelle année on est aimé oui mais voilà
il faut pouvoir supporter ça on m'aurait
dit 2020 oui mais 2024 ça me paraît loin
après cinq ans construit moi ça me
paraît loin
enfin avantage qu'il a c'est que voilà
il veut participer pour pour la tunisie
et c'est le seul athlète tunisiens à
faire du pentathlon moderne donc du coup
il ya peu de concurrence conseillers
avec l'équipe de france
oui voilà oui surtout puis les pentagone
y un français par athlète français par
dont font partie des meilleurs mondiaux
voilà j'ai pas des noms comme d'habitude
du palais non mais mais je sais que tu
es une fille comme je sais tu es une
fille qui court qui court pour pour être
championne olympique au japon et il ya
un gars aussi qui est là pour qui et qui
tirent pour le podium
donc en effet c
c'est très compliqué maintenant voilà
pour la tunisie tant est qu'il est tout
seul pourquoi pas mais mais voilà c'est
vrai curé 44 ans il aura simplement à
établir les minima les minimes
olympiques mais
bon c'est quand même c'est quand même
pas donné à tout le monde et puis à 2
mètres la carcasse pour aller faire le
pour aller courir pour aller courir
c'est quand même pas mal c'est quand
même la quantité de pollution en
natation et en escrime juste sachant que
ces cinq sports justement il est il et
il est assez étonnant cet athlète la
cette espèce de d'armoires d'armoires
étonnante là la réponse à la question
c'est en gros la capacité d'ici d'ici
les cinq ans qui qui sépare de 24 entre
le technique le physique
il a des facilités pour la natation pour
les scream avec une allonge mon avis
assez dingue course à pied il faut il
faut là il faut la moue voire cette
structure-là l'équitation c'est lui qui
m'a un peu de choix pour le pour le tir
là aussi une allonge mais il faut il
faut qu'il ait le bras qui tiennent bien
droit et côté équitation oui elles sont
en fait commencé l'équitation bien
commencé il ya quelques mois je pense
qu'il doit remettre avec des rollers je
crois qu'il doit mettre des rollers son
côté pour ça mais cette maison très mise
à part c'est justement cette capacité là
à maintenir à maintenir ses capacités
physiques et âme à venir aussi le niveau
technique est très exigeant qu'on
s'attaque ici 5 ans et 43 et quelques
tapes et la régie vous attends tu as
beau rêve en occupe
je cours vite
je souhaite c'est un sujet qui m'a qui
m'a beaucoup intéressé quand j'ai étudié
l'ensemble des sujets de l'émission et
du coup j'étais avec quelqu'un à ses
proches dans mon entourage qui lui fait
partie de l'infanterie parachutiste dans
l'armée
parce qu'il s'avère votre compte que les
les épreuves du pentathlon de
d'athlétisme et de natation sont très
très proches de certaines épreuves qu'on
passe dans l'armée dans les troupes
d'élite et quand on a étudié ensemble
les résultats de deux les moyens de
certains bons athlètes du pentathlon
ce militaire me disais ils sont nés on
est déjà loin des meilleurs résultats de
des gens de mon régiment donc il faut
avoir et nous on en a reçu au cadre noir
de saumur les ddd pentathlètes je doute
fort qu'il que même eux mêmes en 2024 il
arrive à atteindre la condition physique
de ses deux de ces garçons là
en plus si ça fait simplement résine
semer un nom qui s'est mis à
l'équitation
là je peux vous dire qu'il faudrait au
moins dix ans d'apprentissage pour
réussir à finir le parcours commence on
joue même avec un cheval qui sépare une
inflation mais c'est une participation
ce n'est pas de gagner ce qui laisse
passer les fils mais parfois aussi je
connais très bien aussi qu'ils se
rapprochent énormément de la boxe qui
est un sport très cardio ce monsieur là
il est très grand mais ici se distingue
aussi par un léger surpoids est
effectivement une grosse carcasse a
soulevé les escrimeurs sont des gens
très très très léger qui se rapproche
vraiment beaucoup des boxeurs et qui ont
un rapport poids taille assez singulier
donc pour l'instant
malheureusement je trouve qu'ils
représentent le moins le pat athlètes
idéal porte à l'esprit les jeux
olympiques c'est villa vanille croit la
raison d'y croire puisque l'objectif
c'est quand même de participer au relais
jeux olympiques je crois que mu des
seychelles 7 907 participants ont arrêté
tout le monde veut gagner mais voilà il
pourrait marquer l'histoire de son pays
les gamins il n'y a plus de chance il ya
participé si vous les verrez pourquoi
pas en tout cas il aurait sa chance sous
drapeau là puisqu'il y aurait pas de
compétiteur il est tout seul et il
aurait sa chance bien évidemment ce cas
il doit lâcher un petit peu le rasta
rockett il de l'attenté de la tunisie
que j'aime bien c'est que sur
l'équitation la grosse problématique de
cette épreuve c'est que il ya un tirage
au sort un client tient il chantait avec
leurs chevaux et à tirage au sort du
cheval avant le vol avant la visite ils
sont montés au pied levé donc d'ici
brise lui faut penser au futur
je sais que ce dernier juge pas tous en
même temps il ya 12 ans les damnés deux
olympiques le france à un des français
avait été avait dit et j'ai été très
désavantagés sur la liquidation
parce que j'ai tiré un cheval trop
petite par rapport à mon gabarit et donc
du coût et du cou aux idées voilà
c'était qui est touché par un cheval
trop petit est là pour le sait les
traces il prend même bâle par exemple
problème c'est le principe des multi des
multi disciplines il y en a 5 à la chine
qui compense l'autre et vice versa mais
c'est une participation financière a
excellé dans une gêne aux malades à
distinguer pour l'instant l'attention du
tir et natation mais bon pour l'instant
pour l'instant
rajoutez la place pour info un raul il
s'entraîne dans les écuries de houdan
voilà vous les connaissez oui mes
confrères alors on va maintenant passer
à notre page des bas dans cette page
débat va s'intéresser à vous mustapha
vous avez annoncé le mardi 2 avril que
vous vouliez vous engager en politique
et notamment
vous auriez dû regarder les tables
d'addition et notamment pour les
élections municipales de l'année
prochaine attrape alors on va voir les
images je rappelle que vous avez été
président du club de football de la
ville de l'étoile sportive de trappes
pendant une quinzaine d'années
il nous est donc venu à l'esprit de
faire une thématique sur le sport et la
politique la question sur ce thème est
ce que le sport peut conduire à la
politique vous votez oui je n'en je
réponds pas on peut être partagé oui ces
informations c'est tout d'abord et
peut-être presque exclusivement due à
l'exposition l'exposition du sport dans
la vie publique et dont et dont la
popularité au sens propre du terme du
sport que la réponse pour ma part et oui
sachant qu'en plus sur les vingt trente
dernières années au moins depuis 98
quand la france est mise à gagner sur
des sports majeurs
le sport a pris une place un peu plus
importante dans la société française on
en parle souvent ici on se dit que
souvent en france le sport est un parent
pauvre dans
dans l'éducation dans la formation des
caractères des hommes et des femmes sur
le territoire mais la désormais il ya
une exposition on est dans des dents des
événements publics on attend des lieux
publics
désormais les hommes politiques qui sont
déjà qu'ils sont déjà sur le terrain
utilise le sport aussi comme un moyen de
promotion n'est pas de propagande de
promotion est justement d'être pour être
au contact avec la population sur
l'ensemble de ces de ces sports donc
c'est un c'est pas universelle s'est pas
géné ral mais pour répondre à votre
question oui le sport peut conduire à
une vie publique et donc à la politique
notamment parle l'exposition et par le
côté presque universel que que s'est
dissipée de représente hélène qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez
je suis d'accord après je pense que par
contre je pense que l'inversé n'est pas
forcément vrai la politique naumenko à
bruz
david douillet qui avait été lue sur la
12e circonscription des îles et en 2012
il a également été ministre des sports
et secrétaires d'état des français à
l'étranger il a été l'un des judokas de
plus titré de l'histoire avec deux
titres olympiques
finalement c'est pas si insolite que ça
exemple les géants de l'emmo-nat il y en
a plein d exemple alors des joueurs de
football qui veulent être élu président
de leur pays en afrique je n'ai jamais
amusé à jouer justement genre jouer à
qui est devenu président du liberia en
2018 après avoir été ballon d'or en 95 m
notamment joué au psg à monaco à l'asse
vidange et alors
et on a bossé un sujet mais version
parmi un bien sûr trois semaines fois
c'est quelque chose de vraiment de lier
et puis après de toute façon il ya aussi
une autre politique c'est à dire que en
effet il ya la politique politicienne
parce que présidents maires d'une maire
d'une commune etc
mais il ya aussi la politique fédérale
un ancien sportif ou un sportif peut
aussi avoir envie de jouer son rôle dans
sa fédération qui lui a qui lui a
apporté
et ça ça pour moi ça reste de la
politique je commence à y réfléchir mais
c'est pas maintenant mais ça que je
commence à en parler depuis depuis
quelques mois et je commence à me dire
j'aimerais peut-être tout à fait de
commencer à faire de la pour le pour le
cyclisme alors ça commence a
certainement par le comité des le comité
régional mais voilà il commence à y
avoir des idées et surtout un ras-le-bol
parce que dans beaucoup beaucoup de
fédérations
c'est beaucoup d'anciens qui dirige et
est aujourd'hui et ça fait des années
que tout le monde est conscient et voilà
ça fait des années que l'on dit voilà il
faut que ça change donc là je pense ne
pas être encore trop vieux mais
justement si je veux apporter des idées
jeunes c'est maintenant qu'il faut le
faire et pas que j'attende de trop
longtemps donc donc voilà c'est c'est
des choses qui sont
c'est des choses qui sait des choses
après il ya très peu de vieux dans
l'esprit mais jeunes enfin et vieux dans
l'esprit mais je voulais dire mais on
peut avoir vu de l'expérience et être et
être jeune d'esprit et c'est vrai que
d'un aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas dans
beaucoup de fédérations
raul est ce qu'il ya des similitudes
entre le sport et la politique
est-ce que vous envoyez moi pour
répondre à cette question de toute façon
je pense que c'est unanime
c'était oui et par mois ce qui est
intéressant c'est de pouvoir en disto
riez certains chemins certains chemins
qui sont dont on pourrait faire l'éloge
et d'autres qui sont un petit peu plus
pervers je pense que quand on est sport
on a été un sportif de haut niveau en
tous les cas suffisamment à haut niveau
pour que pour gagner un certain une
certaine notoriété c'est qu'on a su
réunir des qualités un certain nombre de
qualités qu'on recherche c'est un élu
donc certains sportifs pourraient faire
de très bons élus et avoir une carrière
en politique un autre chemin qui y mène
le sport à la politique
le sportif à la politique et qui je
trouve est un peu plus pervers et
parfois même un peu a dénoncé
c'est quand la politique se sert d'un
sportif ces valeurs
quand justement pour obtenir une
certaine cote de popularité on va se
servir de la popularité d'un sportif
voilà maintenant qu en cite six mais moi
ça me dérange pas mais quand quand quand
nicolas sarkozy a sauvé un certain
moment s'est rapproché badin d'instinct
chanteur rasta qui marche qui marche qui
monte sur scène en chantant à pieds nus
pour démontrer qu'il est un petit peu
populaire ça je trouve que c'est un
petit peu c'est il ya un petit peu de
perversion derrière tout ça quoi
parfois je trouve qu'on se sert un petit
peu de de certains politiques pour
ramener les gens dans son camp mais mais
bon je jeu certains certains sportifs
ont pu seront pu être de très bons
leaders parce que justement ils se
servaient de leur aura et des qualités
qu'ils avaient qu'ils ont eue dans leur
sport pour ensuite le mettre au profit
de la politique donc
mustapha c'est à vous la réponse c'est
oui comme ça je valide tout ce qui a été
dit et d'ailleurs je vais prendre je
vais les prendre pour moi
mon groupe de campagne là j'ai déjà des
gens de qualité qui seront l'expliquer
mais quoi donc la réponse est oui
simplement je vous apporte simplement
mon témoignage terres classées pas du
tout une réflexion que vous avez eu que
je pourrais avoir c'est mon témoignage
la première chose que je tiens à dire
c'est que il faut pas se servir non plus
en l'occurrence tu parlais des
politiques qui se servaient des sportifs
la même façon pour moi c'est très
pervers aussi ça servir d'un club de
foot par exemple ou d'une institution
pour vouloir faire de la politique ça
c'est pas du tout mon cheminement quand
d'autres pourraient le faire ils
seraient tentés de le faire parce que ça
reste quand même quelque chose de
visible de médiatiser on est dans la vie
publique
quand on gère un club de foot ou quand
on gère une grosse institution de sport
et donc du coup on pourrait on pourrait
être tenté d'être de se servir moi je
suis à la trappe il ya 16 ans et on m'a
fait j'ai fait deux campagnes
municipales ou aux mamies tête d'affiche
où on m'a mis dans des listes où on a
mis dans des camps et pourtant le seul
objet que je voulais servir c'est le
club de foot et je me suis même battu en
interne pour qu'on ne fasse part de la
politique à l'intérieur du club et que
on reste bien distincts qu'on distingue
bien les objets on a le foot et ça doit
rester du foot c'est pas un organe ou qu
on doit se servir pour faire de la
politique
donc je suis resté au dehors du champ
politique simplement en étant dans le
club de foot
ç'a toujours été un prétexte pour moi un
prétexte le foot ou la culture
ç'a toujours été un prétexte pour moi
pour aller jouer pour le dire le sport
est important mais on peut aussi élevé
le niveau à la fois physique sportif
mais aussi pour l'intelligence ou
l'ouverture vers autrui etc et je me
suis rendu compte que des tas de choses
à faire au delà du sport et de la
pratique sans en sortir complètement
mais par exemple on a créé une académie
grand format de français parce que c'est
mon moulin moments de vie vont être
sélectionnés aussi par leur savoir leurs
connaissances et leur capacité à
travailler
donc on verrait des milliers jeunes du
club de travail donc nous sommes
on a beaucoup travaillé beaucoup
actuellement on travaille beaucoup sur
la la concentration c'est important dans
le foot
à l'école on travaille beaucoup sur les
cimes de soi c'est important dans le
foot on sport et le travail et demain
des futurs citoyens donc on fait des
sorties citoyenne puisque on va dans des
sorties qui sont dites mémorielles donc
on va voir des on va au musée de la
shoah dans dix jours
on va à verdun on va sur des lieux
mémoriaux on va sur dvd des lieux
symboliques et donc on instruit des
choses importantes qui sont dans
l'éducatif qui sont dans le devenir des
citoyens bref il ya d'autres choses que
le foot ou le sport en lui-même et c'est
là je me suis rendu compte que il y
avait un effet levier par le sport est
tout naturellement je me suis dit il ya
peut-être d'autres effets leviers pour
aller encore plus loin et c'est
finalement le sport qui m'a amené à la
politique et non pas la politique qui
m'amène au sport pour pouvoir en faire
l'objet c'était le club de foot et à
partir de maintenant il ya quelques
quelques jours je me suis lancée sur une
association qui s'appelle engagement au
singulier engagement tra donc je
m'engage pour aller voilà participer à
la vie publique et moi j'engage tout le
monde ceux qui nous écoutent ça fait
partie de la vie démocratique
il faut apporter des choix il faut
apporter des ddd plus value des
différences moi je voudrais que ce soit
sur un bilan un bilan
de mes actions et en même temps des
projets que je vais porter mais oui la
réponse est oui le sport on est très
publique quand on fait ce type de
démarche je suis venu sur très souvent
parce que le sport le commander donc du
coup on devient visible et donc mais
mais c'est plus l'idée de servir c'est
plus l'idée de d'aller sur des y voilà
sur l'éducatif sur des thèmes comme cela
qui fait que l'engagement en politique
où l'engagement public est devenu
nécessaire qu'un noir désir chez allia
tu rajoute à ça évidemment un esprit de
métal à l'esprit de compétition qui peut
ce qui peut qui peut à la fois basculer
du sport à la politique est révolu
parlais tout à l'heure en dise on sait
que ce sont des personnages publics ceux
qui captent la lumière des capitaines
des ddd leader et qui se trouve avoir
des qualités qui sont totalement
incompatibles d'un sportif en politique
et puis il faudra me souffle un de
l'endurance du souffle donc on peut
remettre beaucoup ce critère avec avec
le sportif il ya déjà je vais plus
parler du sujet mais je voulais parler
d'autre chose je simplement un petit
message les ai déjà quasiment terminé un
petit message le vin tension moustapha
vous êtes à 20 avril le 20 avril il ya
le championnat coupe de france carrément
la virémie division sauf que moi je
trouve qu'on a pas appelés quelque chose
d'important c'est quand on parlait des
féminines tout à l'heure je trouve ça
très choquant qu'on n'en parle pas
autant quand on parlait des mecs c'est
quasiment deux ans avant qu'on en
faisait des choux en 24 heures dans
l'édition en fait françois 24/24 on
parle de la coupe du monde dès masculine
des bascules à des hommes étaient des
hommes pour les filles on en parle très
peu mais ça ne veut pas je veux pas que
les filles soient un prétexte pour les
clubs pour avoir des subventions au
pouvoir de l'affichage ou des licenciés
c'est important que le foot
par défi soit je vous donnerai la parole
dans un instant relief varié
moustapha va vous emmener la politique
ah bah là voudront les gens n'ont mené
ces taxes et les électeurs qui décident
je me suis engagé ils voteront vive la
france
non non non municipal un temps des
municipales on espère dégager un
engagement le car et c'est mon objet et
c'est celui qui m'intéresse fait 16 ans
que sur le train et puis je crois que
c'est l'idée de l'engagement de
changement enfin je vais pas faire un
meeting aujourd'hui mais mais c'est pour
dire que voilà c'est des gens qui
voteront
j'ai pas encore fait ce choix parce que
la personne n'est pas important dans
cette histoire je veux participer à des
changements à des transformations tête
de liste si nécessaire avec un on va
dire une liste si nécessaire aussi bien
digéré vous avez 20 secondes j'invite
tous les saint quentinois à venir samedi
20 avril au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il va y avoir les championnats régionaux
et j'ai vu sur les engagés que grégory
baugé étaient inscrits sébastien vigie
inscrits michael d'almeida y aura
l'équipe de france il y aura quant à
l'as far il y aura quentin caldéron des
garçons qui ont participé au dernier
championnat du monde ça va être un
championnat d'île de france de très haut
niveau
donc venez voir et l'entrée sera
gratuite donc vous n'avez pas de vous
êtes en excuses c'est la fin de cette
émission on va terminer par une citation
de l'ancienne joueuse de football
américain aux états unis chami aam
double médaillé d'or aux jo je construis
un feu et chaque jour en m'entraînant
j'y ajoute de l'essence que juste au bon
moment j'allume une allumette
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 78 et une grosse pensée
pour jour ni ce qu'il devrait revenir
bientôt ici sur ce plateau
[Musique]